uh today we are going to be taking a
deep dive
into false beliefs delusion uh
misunderstanding
confusion and something that maybe we
could or should be calling
tribal psychosis and that's where i want
to start today
you may have heard that there are
attempts to do what some are calling
audit the election in the state of
arizona now you might say audit
the election which election was there
recently an election in arizona
that i haven't heard of no the answer is
i'm talking about
the november of 2020 election now more
than six months in the past
and there is a so-called audit of the
vote
taking place now i want to be 100 clear
with you this is going absolutely
nowhere
it's going it's going nowhere the
republican-controlled state senate in
arizona
is undertaking a hand recount and audit
of the ballots and voting machines
in maricopa county which is the state's
largest county
biden won the county it was a republican
stronghold
biden won that county by 45 000 votes
the senate
in arizona has taken possession of over
2 million
ballots and 400 election machines
and has turned them over to be audited
by companies
that include one whose ceo is a
promoter of debunked election conspiracy
theories
understand who's doing this so-called
audit it's
not even clear that the auditors
are compliant with the law about
safeguarding ballots
but forget about all of that for now
here is an interview
with a guy named john braky who's an
official
helping to run this audit and he
explains that
auditors have a special light with which
they can check for
bamboo on the ballots now
why would you be looking for bamboo are
you looking to make
flooring or create bamboo rope out of
the ballots
no they are looking for bamboo fibers
because there's lots of bamboo in asia
i feel like an idiot even saying this
there's lots of bamboo in asia
and these auditors believe that if you
have ballots
with bam trace bamboo fibers on them
they could have been fraudulently
smuggled in from asia take a look at
this
the other day at the press conference
you were talking about bamboo what was
that about
well is that there's accusations that 40
000 ballots were flown in
to arizona into arizona and it was
stuffed into the box
okay and it came from the southeast part
of the world asia okay and uh
and what they're doing is to find out if
there's
bamboo in the paper that camera right
there that they take a picture of the
ballot
if you they can really look at depth
and find out is it a hand mark paper
ballot because that
it's a 5k camera you can see the folds
in the ballot because 92
of all the ballots here should have been
folded because they came in through an
envelope
okay and so they're doing all sorts of
testing to prove
if it was or wasn't and that's very
important because the only way you can
persuade people
on changing is having facts and we're on
a mission for facts
and i'm audit elections usa and what we
do is not about the right or left
audit is an acronym it stands for
americans united for democracy integrity
and transparency in elections
we've been around 17 years we work all
over the country for the last five years
i'm
litigation of florida i've sued in
alabama
i negotiated in virginia i sued in ohio
and i've been in 18 states just working
elections and i all started because of
the bernie sanders election in 2016 with
hillary clinton
i'm the guy who sued the whole state
it's genuinely difficult to know
what the most outrageous thing in the
video is
now as usual the conspiracy theory makes
no sense
because number one bamboo on ballots
wouldn't mean anything
anyway like bamboo can grow in arizona
but also if you wanted to try to steal
the election
with so-called smuggled ballots of or
massive dumps
of fake ballots why would you fly them
in from
asia where they've got to go through
customs much more expensive to ship
you would just make the fake ballots in
arizona it doesn't make any
there's no reason to go to asia for that
and then
you know bamboo fibers i'd be more
interested in look i think
barbecue sauce stains on the ballots
might be more meaningful than bamboo to
be perfectly frank with you
imagine being however old that guy is 65
70 i don't know and being so
totally unable to discern reality from
fantasy
in your life if you went to many
high schools middle schools even and you
presented this story to teenagers about
the bamboo fibers and all of this stuff
your average teenager is going to
question this and this is an adult
who appears to have completely fallen
for all of it is it a tribal psychosis
is it something else i don't know
super cameras to check for bamboo just
imagine what is going on here
it's like a uh it's like a turducken of
wrong it's a duck inside a chicken
inside a turkey
or like the the russian matryoshka dolls
there's just another layer
no matter how much you keep unpacking it
it's a joke and when the world
sees guys like this searching for bamboo
with a special camera
six months after the election we are a
laughingstock once again
and the fact that this is going on makes
me question how we've even survived as a
country
for hundreds of years and believe you me
these auditors were hired to find
fraud they will find something even if
it's just
we found some inconclusive
irregularities we need more ballots to
review
we need more study we need to keep
fighting this they've been hired to find
something
and whether they do or they don't it
will both become part of the conspiracy
as many
of you know the absence of evidence very
often becomes part of the conspiracy
theory for these people
this is not ending anytime soon it will
do nothing it's going nowhere
but i expect more interviews like this
in the future and in fact
we'll have more clips from this
interview
on our instagram which you can find at
davidpakmanshow
and you can find me on instagram
david.pakman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up
for their completely free service at
privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman